bonjour jean marc heureux de me
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors le kobe de recul en grande
bretagne mais les anglais re découvre
les problèmes d'ubs rexie notamment à la
bourse de londres qui est le poumon de
l'économie britannique et qui demande un
accès au marché européen
oui parce que il se passe en
grande-bretagne
phénomène intéressant pendant presque un
an les anglais ont été occupées jallet
vire omnibulé par la lutte contre le coc
vite alors au début ça s'est très mal
passé vous en souvenez jeune boris
johnson
neil est complètement la réalité et
devant les faits et les chiffres la
progression de la cause de la
contamination aussi bas il avait quand
même été obligé de faire de changer de
cap il s'est investi complètement dans
la lutte contre le committee l'a
d'ailleurs été est malade il ya donc
testing de masse traçage sur tout et
surtout vaccination et la grande
bretagne a réussi à s'approvisionner
beaucoup plus vite en vaccins que
l'union européenne à tel point
d'ailleurs que boris johnson s'est
attribué le succès de cette vaccination
en expliquant que la grande bretagne
s'en était mieux sorti que si elle était
restée dans l'union européenne cela vite
presqu'un an après les anglais ont
oublié le problème lié aux briques site
les dirigeants se sont confinés
personnes en angleterre ne s'est
préoccupé de gérer la transition
parce qu'on aurait dû négocier la très
belle sites à bruxelles on dit même que
il était injoignable au téléphone mais
disons qu'après le 31 décembre 2020
c'est-à-dire le break site
officiellement installé ma il s'est rien
passé aujourd'hui que le colis de recul
un peu à tout le monde s'aperçoit que le
break 6 fait plus de dégâts que le coc
vide après locaux vides l'économie
aurait dû repartir elle repart mais avec
le bric site est bien ce qui a été perdu
est perdu et l'adaptation ne s'est pas
fait donc le rebond va être compliqué
premier visé des milieux financiers vous
avez raison alors très concrètement les
fabriques site se manifeste comme en
vrai si tu vas être plus douloureux que
les fécos vite puisque on n'a pas
profité ces périodes transitoires je
vous le disais pour aménager les
conditions de relation comme il était
prévu de le faire entre la grande
bretagne et l'union européenne dont on
s'oriente vers un break c'est dur très
dur
ce qui complique qui alourdit les
relations commerciales avec des
contrôles douaniers avec des contrôles
de normes et de taxes avec un
effondrement de l'activité
dans les ports vous avez des prêts à la
consommation qui augmentent notamment
sur les produits frais vous avez des
ruptures d'approvisionnement
en gros le trafic avec le continent
s'est effondré de 70% alors le succès de
la campagne vaccinale aurait lu
restaurer la confiance
c'est un peu le cas mais vous avez
beaucoup de nos résidents par exemple
qui sont repartis dans leur pays
il ya par exemple beaucoup de pénurie
d'emplois notamment dans les secteurs
qui sont fortement employeurs de
main-d'oeuvre des restaurants et tous
les services en général ils compteraient
y compris même dans les banques les
banques qui sont aperçus qu'un certain
nombre de leurs salariés était rentré
sur le continent nous embarque les
partisans du bric sites ont un sens je
pense est il que la bretagne libérer des
contraintes de l'europe allait attirer
des investisseurs étrangers
oui oui absolument c'était le grand
argument des prêts qu sitter les bas les
partisans nous expliquer que la grande
bretagne pouvait même se transformer en
singapour de l'europe un paradis fiscal
donc ça pouvait être intéressant pour
les américains pour les asiatiques mais
à condition qu'il puisse accéder au
marché européen là l'europe a maintenu
ses règles et ses contraintes
il n'y a eu aucune négociation avec
londres londres n'a d'ailleurs pas
entamer négociations actuellement le
passeport financiers c'est-à-dire ce qui
aurait permis au financier de passer en
europe et plus bas n'est pas valable
alors vous avez un indicateur drac
d'attractivité par exemple des pays qui
inquiètent il fait chaque année il est
sorti en début de semaine à le résultat
pour 2020 est intéressant le pays le
plus attractif en europe ça va vous
paraître paradoxal c'est la france qui
ont dépuis tous ces ennuis reste le pays
le plus attirant et le deuxième pays
c'est l'angleterre
ce qui veut dire que il y a plus
d'investisseurs à sortir de l'angleterre
aujourd'hui qu'à venir à londres
troisième pays l'allemagne l'allemagne
qui est tombé en panne pour des raison
d'incertitudes politiques notamment liés
à la montée de ses colonies et les
professionnels de la bourse de londres
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent très simple ils
veulent le passeport ils cherchent à
préserver leur leadership
ils veulent continuer d'avoir accès au
marché européen ils veulent un passeport
financier être dans le pré qu site et
profiter des avantages de l'union or ça
ça paraît pas possible
la re le beurre l'argent du beurre ils
eux
normand l'europe s'est organisée papa de
payer certaines de ses banques sur
francfort paris ou amsterdam
ça a été un peu lent c'est en train de
se faire ce qui va se passer est très
intéressant on s'aperçoit finalement une
industrie financière aussi puissante
soit elle ne peut que ne peut
fonctionner que si elle est adossée à
une économie réelle
sinon c'est un casino singapour
fonctionne c'est vrai parce que
singapour est adossé à la chine c'est la
porte d'entrée alacchi l'ordre était
puissant c'est vrai parce qu'elle était
adossé à l'europe c'était la porte pour
aller en europe maintenant que la porte
de l'europe fermer les acteurs de
londres vont avoir plus de mal
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre un
édito à revoir sur les réseaux sociaux
et on retrouve mercredi prochain dans la
matinale